Memorial Stadium at UC Berkeley has one
critical fault Hayward Fault running
right down the middle and under the
goalpost so the University recently
embarked on a 321 million dollar seismic
retrofit sections of seating over the
fault have been converted into surface
rupture blocks they're built on stone
columns and they're sitting on slippery
polyethylene sheets and three feet of
sand all that reinforcement means the
surface rupture block can handle a
vertical displacement of up to two feet
without crumbling the press box
cantilever it out above the stadium's
Westside weighs a thousand tons and
could fall down onto the stands so
engineers designed vertical walls of
steel cable reinforced concrete and they
put 16 silicon filled shock absorbers
between the walls and the seats result
the box shakes but stays upright